hey hey according to this
it could be an acute subdural hematoma
great get in there and operate dr.
Google it's a fungus they think benign
fungus great title for your memoir come
all the way up you all the way up I
am surrounded by snakes
he did not fire me he said it was just
gonna take a little longer well I think
he meant to say was that he wished that
mom gave birth to a can opener because
at least then it would be useful I take
over and we just you know you two under
me co-presidents can we think about it
of course I thought about you you
lack killer instinct you're wet you're
green you're intellectually insecure
you're not emotionally sure enough you
have a digit that's enough I'm not
saying I would make a better CEO that
son said it's not unsaid when you say it
all in favor of the vote of
no-confidence in Loudoun Roy me my hand
is red sir
oh no Judas you better be smelling
your armpit Romulus it's my
company you are a nobody
like Jesus Christ
amateur hour and then
circuses people come to us because we
don't sell them on injury no packet of
bleeding-heart United Nations
Volvo gender-bender horseshit why can't
he come to us well I guess he's the
president Californian shrunken
little raisin he's selling me things I
wanted a fair price so what's next
fellatio okay how's the hooker with a
heart of gold nice vest WOM scans it's
so puffy think you owe me what's that
stuff with your hopes and dreams just
think it's the best time to into shop
this is the time to get your conscience
out and shout hey look at me I cannot
tell him hi I'm a good little boy look
at mine dingdong maybe you'll meet a
wealthy widow and you can seduce her
with their sad eyes you keep you as a
pet in Westchester I'm thankful that I
I'm gonna be married
into one of the most kind and loving
families of the world are you not to be
married anymore this whole family
is the nest of vipers they'll wrap
themselves around you and they'll
suffocate you cousin Greg is moving to
Staten Island no no I don't know my god
just looking at a place out there Greg
is getting the ferry to work check out
Bryan Ferry dude why stop at the ferry
just come in from Cleveland on the
Greyhound we're talking to each other on
the poop deck of a majestic schooner
it's the salty brine stinging my
weather-beaten face no the why the
are you wearing a pair of deck shoes man
I'm in Canada Canada Canada with the
health care the ennui why is that
sock I'm driving my grandpa down for
Thanksgiving Oh Greg your grandpa
yeah okay you're on you're on
speakerphone
Tom I hear you been from him what I what
I hear you been for him but he
you I don't know what you're
laughing about what promise when you
laugh please do it at the same volume
with everyone else we didn't get you
from a high uniform thanks Bob right I
can pretty corpse waxy like an unshaven
candle candle oh no sassy little
it looks demented why is he so shiny
you're a prick he's like a sex
robot for dad to it was like an old
beaten dog well he's both of those
things and also a piece of check
out Papa Smurf house telling the
family cow for magic beans oh yeah yeah
that's right yeah just a a sex
pest in a grand old Duke of dork on a
Central Asian vacation no nothing to see
here
where's the actual head doctor guy I
wouldn't know no one tells me anything
well I hope you can cure your serious
case of being a oh you
good news is that the Pierces are
entertaining our offer but bad news
they're inquiring about your moral
character
that's okay nobody here has any glaring
substance abuse issues that almost
brought down the company right steer on
to gossip investments all right movies
if you don't have a wider cultural
interests so what if your wider cultural
interest says hey jerk into Instagram
just asking for a friend
o me you talking about me just just know
your role and execute well my worry is
that Kendall may come across as too cool
and likable this was supposed to be
choreographed that's about as
choreographed as a talk any on
rollerskates quick question do you think
he even knows what a jail is he
literally only knows it from monopoly
I'm still applying for the job of the
President of the United States do you
think that that's like a natural
progression from never done nothing
never to the most important job in the
world
well like could you maybe get a little
experience of like a CVS or just like
nickel hand drops under bridge the whole
know your role
he'll my fellow tournament I returned
from real America bearing the gift of
sight Roman Memorial but you treated me
like I'm a piece of you are a piece
of you do the management
training program floor we're gonna
slaughterhouse learn the price of a
gallon of milk is his obsession
with milk you know who drinks milk
kittens and perverts so how is it going
gobbledy go yourself Oh amazing
marry kill the executive floor
executive floor mm-hmm kill ray of
course Elsa marry Jerry Jerry marry
Jerry there's a small pool you'd marry
Jerry you sick Jerry you like Jerry
you know if I were capable of any sudden
movement I was totally pounce on you
right now should we get married what you
know about that
like an equivalent of a thing like I
abduct you and force you to live with me
that's not equivalent no I guess you are
family and he does treat family
different yeah no sure although he did
once call me the of Monte Cristo
my drink have a drink you beautiful
Ichabod Crane you Greg this is not
Charles Dickens world okay you
don't go around talking about principles
man the off secret Greg look actual
envelope this receipts
oh but they're not in fact receipts Oh
crack you're a criminal mastermind
what polyglot genius could ever hope to
crack your impenetrable code shut up
easy sorry here's a strategy in tone why
don't you pipe down until you come and
tell me I've got a grandson coming hmm
or are you shooting blanks Bohr on the
floor over there
Jerry stand up Donna actually I to be
perfectly honest I've I've had a few
doubts you see everybody do you see
honesty yeah some doubts - Oh
doubter over there on the count of three
the last piggy to eat a sausage is the
mole that doesn't seem like a very good
system I can't reveal my sources I put
it to Craig yep
buckle up folks we're gonna get an
invite to the great national latrine see
who wants to take a public dump mr.
is going to Washington no I'm not
dignifying that question with an
answer you can both off if you look
at the ledger packet 15 B by a Gregory
Hirsch is that someone known to you Mr
Wong scans uh-huh no no sorry no no no
Dom hmm oh yes yes sorry yes no known
known to me yes in that sense yes do you
know what is special about the hours
between 3:00 a.m. and 5:00 a.m. on the
night of March 12th I know sir that was
the only two-hour period in which you
did not send an email to mr. Hirsch with
the title
you can't make at omelette without
breaking some Greg's you sent the same
email to him 67 times in one evening I
guess it was a joke I think the obvious
choice isn't I hate to say it because
he's such a swell guy is Tom how about
Tom with some Greg sprinkles
what what precisely are Greg sprinkles
like a Tom sundae with a with a little
Greg cherry on top what the
hate my chicken huh so what next
Sookie's into my potato salad all
right all rise for Pope big dick like
Romans amongst you Greeks I'm sure you
find this all rather a big follow go to
the boisterous you get me I will
you up
meeting over
Paco off off off that's
off oh oh oh oh
thanks Carl
up how about you off you
off if you can't do it off good
right
is it whiskey time shut the up and
I'm proud of my family who helped me get
here what are you waiting for the kiss
off be gone bye-bye
you